would you think of the Irishman you love
it I did think that it was really I was
very emotional I got like a tear in my
eye at the end because I sat on the
theater and watch it at the Hamptons
Film Festival and my wife had to go into
the city with the kids ahead of me and I
said I'm gonna stay and watch this movie
because I really feel like I got a scene
on a big screen and I watched the film
and the I thought you were never gonna
see these guys do this again this is it
made you sad that made me sad and it
made me sad I think of all the pleasure
think of all the moments because
Scorsese in his documentary about
American film says if you remember the
plot of a movie it's not a great you
remember moments and how many moments do
we remember these guys how many moments
to remember you know Pesci thoughts guts
I mean you just cry ya just cry I got
called Joe I called you and I said I
can't tell you how beautifully Hewlett's
movie I said you are great in this movie
I said I hope it brings you everything
you could possibly hope for and he's
like yeah thanks Alex it's really
fantastic
you know I interviewed Pacino right
Pacino I'm gonna graduate from NYU 14
years later they come to ask me for
money right and my assistant is a kid
from LA he came let me goes ask him for
the degree mark what you say he was
asking for the degree they're shaking
you down for the dough coming you want
the degree I go you're a [ __ ] genius
I go back in the room and I walk and I
go and listen I don't want you guys to
just give me the degree but I'm willing
to help me figure out how it go like
independent study so we say you're gonna
write a paper I love that you merde I
mean I wanted a real degree you want a
degree I went to school pretty
accessible guy want my I want my [ __ ]
degree like what about a paper but the
applicability of method acting training
or real method actor to a person with
his career in film and theater and the
only person that fit was al cuz he kept
going back to the theater and doing
theater so I contact him and he agrees
let me interview him while he's shooting
Carlito's Way Wow and I said to him what
do you do when you're as gifted as you
and you're working on the film I mean
you're a huge movie show where the
greatest movie stars ever live and
you're doing a movie and the other
people don't hit the ball back in the
same way if everything goes oh I don't
get involved in that at all I like no no
no I just say you know I like everybody
in the business is talented you wouldn't
be here you wouldn't be in the business
unless you were talented
he said they say he has a talent for
telling jokes he has a talent for
singing a song everybody is talented at
they're all talented some of us are just
more conscious by the way excellent
Pacino voice and you do all of all
Pacino's old pal and young al right when
you do young al you gotta go up higher
like this he says to the black kid and
it's always in Serpico yeah what he said
we're gonna go for a walk we're gonna
take a walk
you will me without cuffs you [ __ ] me
I'm gonna put one in your back i'ma put
one in your back that's Serpico and then
he gets into who he goes down right Bob
all those guys I worship them